Đà một trong những ngày kinh tế mối nhọn với kinh đại sức hầu hàng chục tí U.S.D.
Nhưng ngày thủy sản Việt Nam đang đối mặt với nghịch liy,
sản phẩm đã chất lượng quốc tế lại khó chính phục tị trường lộ điện.
Tinh trọng này đặt ra yêu cầu phải thay đổi tư duy,
chính lược tiếp cận tị trường để thủy sản Việt không còn là người la trên chính mâm cơm của mình Việt.
Theo các chuyên gia, một trong những khó khăn lở nhất là sự cạnh tranh không cần sức bây ra.
Sản phẩm thủy sản triếp biến của giến nghiệp chính gạc,
tôn tủy các tiêu chuẩn hát toàn thực phẩm có ra khó hơn 28.5 xò với hàng trôi nổi,
cáng chất lượng chính thị trường.
Điều này khi người tiêu dùng vốn quên với sản phẩm tư dống khó chấp nhận.
Một thách thức khác đến từ hàng nhập khẩu,
với thị trường lựa diệu khoảng một tí U.S.D.
thủy hại sản nhập khẩu đã chiếm tới bố mê phần chăm thi phần,
một phần sau tâm liy sính ngoại và giới nghiệp trong nước chương khai thác đúng khẩu vị người dùng.
Để dài quyết tình trạm này, các dành nghiệp phải thay đổi tư duy có thể chương lỗi địa là thiêu một tiêu để chú động nghiệp kêu,
tế thi. Đồng thời, cân ra sản phẩm, đầu tư vào báo bi, nhắn mắt bắt mắt,
mình bạc mùnh gốc sản phẩm và xe dự chủi giá chi khai kiến.
Hí đó, thị sản Việt mới có thể chú vốn và phát triển bình bứng trên chính xinh nhạc.